[Musique]
bonjour je suis Marc Badaoui je suis le
gérant du restaurant libanais taska
medzébar à Voisins-le-Bretonneux et
aujourd'hui on va faire ensemble un
caviar d'aubergine
[Musique]
évidemment on commence avec l'aubergine
et avant de la mettre au four pour la
griller on va planter avec une
fourchette ou un couteau quelques
entailles ça va éviter qu'elle explose
au four
on va tout simplement venir gratter
le fond de l'aubergine c'est
complètement fondant
plus vous allez en mettre plus vous
allez avoir du goût de sésame plus ça va
être consistant et gourmand
[Musique]
like on a écrasé dans le sel
et qu'on va venir verser avec le jus de
citron et la pâte de sésame on va venir
ajouter de l'eau
un peu de mélange 4 épices
hop
voilà ça va énormément parfumer on va
mettre
nos aubergines je vais pas tout mettre
je vais en garder un peu
trop bon comme ça
mais on mélange ensuite vous pouvez
goûter et assaisonner à votre convenance
alors on va ensuite servir ça dans un
bol
hop là un petit peu de coriandre
un petit peu de persil
on badigeonne
d'un petit peu d'herbe on avait une
grenade qu'on a décortiqué petite astuce
la grenade avant de la décortiquer
faites la rouler sur votre plan de
travail comme ça on appuyant ça fait
décoller les grenades ensuite vous la
coupez en deux et puis vous prenez une
cuillère et vous prenez chaque moitié et
vous tapez dessus comme ça et ça fait
que ça tombe c'est beaucoup plus rapide
[Musique]
je mets la grenade
petite astuce que je vous ai dit
rapidement au début faites bien la sauce
sésame à part comme ça si vous en reste
vous en faites pour de l'aubergine mixez
avec les pois chiches ça va vous donner
un ou mousse et ça vous servira
également de sauce pour agrémenter votre
plat principal
[Musique]